[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five ken coleman ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author host of the ken coleman show is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
now ken talks about careers and talks
about your job on siriusxm on 75 radio
stations and on a very popular youtube
and podcast show as well all one show
just shows up a lot of different ways a
lot of different places so we'll take
your questions about your jobs about
your life and about your money and i'm
happy to do that today
uh around ramsey uh we are grieving
today
a friend of mine over 25 years uh talk
radio host phil valentine passed away
over the weekend
and uh you know i've been friends a long
long time we uh did a lot of uh we've
been on the radio same radio stations
many times we've been on opposite radio
stations lately here in nashville uh but
we've always been good friends and
always shared a lot of uh viewpoints and
um
[Music]
of course we've been in touch with
he's been
battling covid
and we've been in touch with him his
wife the family over the last many many
weeks while this struggle has gone on
but it
um it ended with him graduating to
heaven on saturday and um
just uh uh
kind of hard to believe a little bit
yeah still a young man somebody that's a
contemporary viewers you guys came
together in wtn and both of you had
national influence
uh friends in fact i was just thinking
uh when i got the email from you on
saturday that we were the last time i
was with him and you in the same place
was uh
at your house back in march yeah we had
a bunch of uh a bunch of influencers
there and uh got a picture with him with
mike huckabee i sent it to mike um and
sent it to his wife susan as well
uh over the weekend i found that in my
in my roll up there sharon actually had
the picture sharon oh well my wife and
so but we've been again friends a long
long time and um
you know this brings about a lot of
things um
but one of the saddest parts of the
whole thing is to watch the number of
people in america today
that are happy that someone is dead
that they disagree with yeah
on anything i mean he was a conservative
talk radio so the number of people that
didn't like his stance on
covet issues or on political issues that
have come out and um
said they're glad he's dead i mean you
guys
really um
there are people that i absolutely
detest
what you believe
i think you're a backward socialist
communist
but i am not if you die
and and you say something about that
doesn't say anything about him when you
do that it says something about you
you classless immature
unbelievable people yeah
and and twitter is particularly bad
because twitter's just full of trolls
billy goat gruff needs to get in there
and deal with the trolls on twitter but
um that's an old one but yeah
but you know it's just um
it's
aggravating and i you know i've never
i've done a lot of things it's run my
mouth on a lot of things i've said a lot
of bombastic crazy stupid butt stuff
over the years but i have never trashed
somebody that died yeah happy they died
because i disagree with them i got the
same thing when rush limbaugh died
it's unbelievable we've dehumanized
ourselves i mean now it's like if you
don't agree with me or even worse if you
say something uh with some passion and
some fervor that i really disagree with
you are now dehumanized and so we're
treating people as though we've we've
forgotten that they have a family we've
forgotten that there are there's a wife
involved
brothers sisters friends kids
again just just to reiterate
when you do that it doesn't say anything
about no no it says something about you
it says that you're you know that you
really are a child you really are an
immature child and political people have
done that i noticed one of the senators
or somebody the other day said something
about they wish mitch mcconnell was dead
i saw that coming on news feed sure and
it's just you know i hope he died or he
got covered i hope he dies from it or
something like that oh my god you know
even if you were so
unbelievably horrible person that you
thought that and probably all of us are
that horrible a person we probably have
thought it yeah you know
but but the fact that you open up your
mouth and say it out loud worse than
that you do it in a public manner on
social media
just says what a horrible place we have
come to
uh in our decorum we ought to be able to
argue and fuss
and fight and and take an idea and
wrestle that idea or that concept to
mask or not to mask
to vaccine or not to vaccine to block
out people based on either one of those
or not you ought to be able to have that
argument and have a discussion about
that without absolutely having to
destroy someone
and just believe that
and it's just horrible horrible because
phil of course had come out uh initially
and later on recanted that but it come
out against vaccine the vaccine and then
uh you know once he had coven was in the
hospital he said he wished he had taken
it and that was his stance on it and his
family came out with a statement from
him on that um and regardless of that
but i mean the number of people it's
just it's sickening it's very sickening
so anyway we'll be um um actually we're
hosting the funeral here oh the service
is going to be here at ramsey in our
amphitheater oh and um it's the only
place large enough and it's outdoors
which uh family was concerned about it
you know being outdoors with covid and
everything so um
we'll be doing that but uh uh on quite
an honor yeah to get to do that yeah uh
but um
yeah i just think some of you guys out
there and you know what if you don't
listen to the ramsay show because i say
stuff like this that's fine
i'll get along without you
i'll be just fine
um and you know if you're that kind of
person that says and does stuff like
that i just assume you went somewhere
else
it'd be fine
because if you said it in my presence in
my physical presence i'm not sure i'd be
um
i'm not sure i wouldn't be spending some
time somewhere in the pokey after that
well that's just it dave nobody does
they don't have that
they're powered social media digital
courage yes the social media uh filter
as if you were
from a redneck neighborhood if you said
stuff like that to somebody's face you
wouldn't have any teeth yeah you get you
know you say something about their mama
yeah you get jacked up yeah you know
it's absolutely right and so but
nowadays you can do that and be a
complete wuss and hide in your mother's
basement yes
and so uh but you don't have the courage
no to do it anywhere else we don't even
have your real name or real face on that
by the way wouldn't even have most of
the things that these people lob out on
on social media if they had to say it to
somebody's face dave they would choke
just trying to get the words out yeah
just trying to get it out the boldness
the cowardice
and the thing about those of us in talk
radio
it's our job to say stuff to mess you up
that's right and we're good at it and
yeah and phil and me and people like us
that have done this on a national level
for decades
it's our job
to have the courage to say things that
you're thinking
or have the courage to say things that
really upset you
it is and we're good at our job
so you know that that's the thing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today rick is with us in
saratoga new york hi rick welcome to the
ramsay show
hey guys how are you such an honor to be
speaking to you you too what's up
uh so i kind of have a career question
for you guys uh my wife and i were on
baby step two
we have 180 000 in student loan debt
and i'm in the process of working with
proximity principal
so i have a great mentor and he's
kind of helped me get clear on where i
want to go
and has offered to
make some introductions for some
informational interviews
and just wanted your advice on this kind
of get started face on the process you
know how i can put my best foot forward
to avoid
yeah well you know here's the thing if
you're really really prepared in the
interview process itself and it seems
like uh you kind of broke up is he
helping you with some of these
connections so you're going into these
interviews a little bit warm is that
what i'm understanding
yeah so he's he's offered to make an
introduction to a couple people perfect
areas that i might want to go into
here's the deal you're already way ahead
of the rest of the candidates because
he's got some credibility obviously over
there so they're going to hear good
things about you before the interview so
i would keep it simple this is a very
stressed out
environment for a lot of people to do an
interview so the key is to prepare
prepare prepare they've done some
research i read some research recently
that the brain will retain 70 percent of
what's in it even under the most
stressful environment so
uh i've got a little phrase that i tell
people relentless preparation leads to
reflexive performance and it's just like
these quarterbacks that perform under
pressure in the two-minute drills
they've watched the film they've
practiced the two-minute drill the plays
are gonna run over and over and over
again and we've got a free interview
guide called how to win the interview at
ken coleman.com i'll make sure that
kelly gets it to you it's absolutely
free and we go through specific
questions
that we know from research that hiring
managers tend to ask and then i teach
you how to ask questions and this would
be the advice i'd give the most
important part of the interview rick how
do you put your best foot forward is by
asking really good questions in the
interview a big mistake that people make
is they feel like it's a one-way
conversation that you're just answering
questions but there's gonna be time for
you to be able to return the serve and
asking questions like what kind of
person wins in this organization
what do you love most about the culture
here what's your leadership style things
like that we give you more examples in
this free guide but that's how you stand
out rick because you look prepared you
look insightful and and you also are
showing enthusiasm by asking those kinds
of questions that's how you stand out
many times by the questions that you ask
you know and it you know just if you
kind of think about it it's not like
some kind of technique no the biggest
technique here is to just
flip the uh moccasins for just a second
welcome welcome all the other guys let's
pretend you were interviewing someone
do you want to interview a wet dishrag
rag
who only responds yes or no when you ask
a question
no because that's what they're going to
be when they work for you is a wet dish
rag right and they're not bring no
energy no creativity no add value to the
thing so if you're interviewing and
you're hiring someone what do you want
them to be well i want to see some
energy yeah some enthusiasm some ability
to think on your feet i want a little
bit of intelligence here hello yeah and
um and and i want to know by the way
you're handling yourself that you're
there for what you can bring rather than
what you can take yes and and so i i
love questions i mean i i don't know the
techniques and all this stuff they've
got all these interview techniques how
do you match two how do you match uh
three different unmatching socks in the
dark and all this bs
try to figure out people's thinking
skills or whatever but i just like to
you know i i
i if you were interviewing someone and
you were going to give them your money
to work for you yeah
and it's money that you don't have
anymore because you gave it to them
yeah
then you want to hear them to say things
like
uh if i were here how could i add the
most value yeah to this company or this
organization
and like you said what do people that
were that work out here that that are
your best ones the ones that win what do
they look like and sound like yes and i
wonder if i'm one of those that's right
and and so not like how you know what's
your work hours yeah how many holidays
do you take off how much time do i get
off
[Laughter]
yeah and you know let me help you you're
already off right yeah thank you we're
done with that where this interview's
over because all you're trying to figure
out is what you can take or what you can
add and sp to your point speaking
intelligently about the position because
you've done your homework on the company
about the product about the service that
they're about and you know the job
description so well that instinctively
you're going well listen i this is what
you're looking for and i bring these
particular talents to the table i'm a
good fit here because of this skill
because of this experience it's the
ability to weave yourself to your point
dave how do you add value because we
know from research that the number one
thing hiring managers are looking for in
the interview is will this person help
me win that doesn't sound that's not
selfish it's just duh
but that's what they're looking for and
you got to be the candidate they go
that's who i want to give the ball to
because i think they're going to help us
win
and that's what it's about coach i'll
leave it all on the field so preparing
to the point that you're not going to
have your nerves take over that's where
people get tripped up they didn't
prepare they kind of go in and they're
shooting from the hip so then when they
when the anxiety hits and the stress
hits then they say something really well
the brain can freak out on you yeah when
you say something like
like just that that becomes legendarily
bad yeah you end up on a well i was
interviewing this time this time and he
said someone though you'll be one of
those guys right yeah right so
yeah that website worst interviews i've
ever been on yeah it's legendary and the
same thing's true if you are the
interviewer oh this is so many leaders
blow it on the front end they don't do a
good job interviewing and no wonder they
get duped and somebody will just lie
right to them it's an acting job they
don't know who they've hired because
they don't prepare
um we do a whole we do a whole lesson on
that at entre leadership it's called the
intentional interview you've got to know
what you're looking for so you know what
to ask i mean it's it's extraordinary we
don't have time to unpack it but the
amount of lost money through
productivity and just replacement costs
for small businesses and even large
businesses is all about the hiring
process so it's
it's uh
there's a lot of room for improvement we
at ramsey solutions we're working on
that we're diving always always open
phones a triple eight eight two five
five two two five kim is in minneapolis
hi kim how can we help
hi it's so nice to talk to y'all you too
well i've got a quick one um i
sold a classic car
and i have about 23 000 dollars and i
don't we don't owe anything except our
mortgage and we have about
58 years old 800 000
in our investments so do i put it toward
the investments of the house
what do you owe on the home
about 190 and it's worth about 560. good
for you okay well you've done very very
well
well um we teach folks to be putting 15
of your income away once you're
debt-free other than the home and have
an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses i'm
assuming you've done all of that
right
and then we say beyond that make sure
kids college is funded i'm guessing
you've probably done all that and beyond
that the next goal is to pay off the
house and so i'm leaning into this house
as hard as i can i'm not putting more
than 15 of your income away you've got a
nice nest egg
and so you need to get this house
knocked out should be your next big goal
i'm curious
i don't usually get a lady
calling me now this is sexist i know but
i just don't usually get a lady calling
me saying she sold her classic car
usually that's a guy and he's somewhat
sobbing as he's discussing selling his
classic car so what's the story here
well the story is that it was my
brothers
and my brother
passed away
and it's a 73 datsun 240z and i have had
it
since probably
85. wow
and um and you kept it just right you
kept it because you love the car or
nostalgia with your brother
mostly it is a really cute little car
yeah but my brother but in minneapolis
driving around in adults in 240z nine
months of the year is probably not very
doable yeah and i don't want it in the
salt yeah yeah and so pretty much it's
steamed all the time yeah so it kind of
used up its usefulness for
nostalgia and or enjoyment
correct time to move on and get your 23
000. look at you okay well thanks for
letting me ask that because it might be
offensive to ask it but i was just
curious because
i didn't see that coming did you i did i
did there you go
that's cool good for you well done kim
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage jared and christina are
with us hey guys how are you hey dave hi
welcome welcome where do you guys live
glendale arizona all right welcome to
nashville and all the way over here to
do a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off
168 000 over six years six years wow
okay and your range of income during
that time
about 100 to 130 okay cool good and even
more now all right good good what do you
guys do for a living i'm an engineer
and i'm a registered dietitian oh
wonderful okay good to have you guys
what kind of debt was the 168 000 it was
our mortgage you paid off your house
look at the weird people
all right excellent job way to go how
old are you two i'm 35. i'm 32. and you
have a paid for house we sure do in
glendale arizona what's this house worth
uh but the market now it's about 450.
yeah i guess i like it that feels good
doesn't it wow look at you weirdos you
guys are awesome man way to go so you
said 35 and 32. 35 and 32. wow that is
so cool all right tell me the story what
happened in your 20s
well
so i have to like poke fun at him for
just a second because
when we first got married our church was
offering an fpu class and i was like hey
i think we should do this my brother and
sister-in-law have followed your plan
and they're a preacher and a teacher and
so it's like if they can make ends meet
following the system we should do this
yeah and he was like no
i am not cutting out my credit cards i
don't need to do that that's like how
come um but by the time before we even
finished the class oh you did do the
class we did we i convinced him we did
it
and before we even had finished he
actually
you know jared that's the way i would
have gone into the class
like this guy's some kind of snake oil
salesman this grifter what's he doing
i would have had my shields my cynical
butt and i've got this gift of cynicism
i would have been just like you pretty
much but he ended up picking up a second
job actually getting up at like three
o'clock in the morning to work for fedex
for a couple hours before he went to his
big boy job wow to pay off his student
loans you went all the way to the dark
side sure did
how much did you pay off on the student
loans they were just about 19 000 but
you just knocked them out fast within a
year of that class wow wow
okay this is so interesting okay so you
go to the class your brother-in-law and
sister-in-law were in there they're
teachers you're an engineer i mean
you're good with numbers yes sir so that
adds to the arrogance of this obviously
that's what i would have done that's
exactly what i would i don't need this
guy i can add i'm gonna pay a guy to
tell me how to handle money that's crazy
that would have been exactly what i
would have been saying all you people
out there that make fun of me and say
that i'm just like you
so that's so fun so uh
do you go really against your will just
to please your wife because you love
your wife yep
and you go in there kind of with your
like your arms crossed right yeah that's
what now this is me so uh what happened
in the class what changed you
uh i think you just convinced me that
this way was the better way to run with
money and not the way i was going
so
i liked what you presented and i was
like let's do this let's save up money
and buy a house let's save up money and
retire early let's
let's live the goals and dreams we want
to live he makes that sound too simple
yeah yeah because i mean we went from
the arms cross to you just convinced me
yeah i'm gonna get up at three in the
morning i'm gonna work two jobs
i'm a morning person yeah okay he's a
hard worker now yeah
there was drive
what drove you to go that intense i mean
you know what i mean you really went
quick
that's a good question i think it's just
seeing what debt really was and
understanding
that i was owing them that money and i
had to pay it every month and
just being able to
see freedom and feel freedom it's
that's what really motivated me
you're you're a rip the bandaid off guy
yeah yeah so he once he's in he's all in
yeah i think he there was blue face
paint some william wallace braveheart
like you got angry at it
you got angry that's passion that's
awesome that's so cool very good
very good so um
uh
for our listener's sake i am curious
for because again i i'm we're poking at
this but the uh
the way our minds work is similar
what what what happened in there
uh for you what what lens were you
looking at it through the spiritual lens
the math lens the process lens what was
it that when you saw that you went oh
maybe and then yeah
you know what i'm talking about yeah i'm
curious what happened inside your brain
i think it's some of both math and
spiritual math yes i hadn't been
presented that information like you had
presented it to
do that and i
didn't understand how
practical it was that we could win with
money and make that much progress and be
where we are today
so i was just kind of floating along and
seeing the map that i could do that i
could save up money to pay
for my house and pay it off and
okay that you know that really clicked
with me well thank you thank you for
letting me delve into that i apologize
because i know
you're the hero of the story but it's a
a process that used you to get there
that's so cool well done guys
well done all right now you've done it
you're not even 40. you have a half a
million dollar house almost paid for
uh no debt in the whole freaking world
and you make 100 130 during this time
uh what is the secret people want to
know to getting out of that
so
i told you that if you ask this i get to
answer this question okay good
because the secret is i made pennies and
i married somebody who didn't make
pennies
and so that's the secret just marry
somebody who can uh help you but no the
real secret i think is we we just were
um like i think guided obviously by your
principles um and so that we could
always be on the same team um we just
knew like we didn't have to ever
question what decisions we were going to
make or how we were going to make them
we were just on the same page um
we just we just knew the plan so and my
answer was to marry a frugal wife
both of you good marriage points answers
across the board made it easier yep yeah
it does help to make more if you if
you're trying to get out of the hole the
size of your shovel matters
you know and so you know going and doing
the
fedex thing and then also being diligent
at work and seeing your household income
come up over this time and getting those
raises and so forth that that makes a
big difference yeah i'm just curious now
you've got the house paid off you guys
are very very young
what are you dreaming about now what has
changed now that you've kind of got this
final debt out of the way
that changes every day
it's what i love about it is we have the
freedom of options yeah so we've been
talking about house upgrades or by
vacation house or
you know
saving more for the kids and everything
it's just
we have the freedom too and we're still
deciding what we want to do oh dream is
a lot more fun now it is yeah it's a lot
more real
that's cool well done well done what was
the hardest part of the journey for
y'all
so i
we're i don't know that's
we we're very very very blessed and we
really don't feel like there was a super
super hard part of the journey for us
because again like we were we're
naturally frugal people we're naturally
logical people so you know if we don't
want to have debt then we don't buy
things we can't afford and whoa
i know can you run for
congress yes um yeah so i think there
was a lot of things like we obviously
were very diligent and um living within
our means but also just very very
fortunate well you brought the kiddos
with you what are their names and ages
let's get them in the shot here
we have kinsley who's eight
edens who's five and the maniacal meyer
who's almost two all right go meyer i
love it all right a hundred and we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter in your story
you have changed your legacy copy the
total money makeover for you to give
away and hopefully someone will see the
logic in that when you do that for them
so thank you guys so much we're so proud
of you guys
absolute rock stars heroes well done
look at that grave family jared
christina kinsley eden and meyer from
glendale arizona 168 000 paid off in six
years making a hundred to 130 count it
down house and everything let's hear a
dead free scream three
two
one
we're dead free
love it
well done you guys
very well done man
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
he is the author of the number one
best-selling book the proximity
principle and a brand new book that's on
pre-sale right now from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work
you love from paycheck to purpose the
clear path to doing work you love he is
you can pick that book up at
ramseysolutions.com
add a deal be sure and check it out
during the month of august we're also
giving away free money on the website no
purchase necessary so you need to go in
and sign up for the giveaway of the free
money and august is almost over uh we've
noticed that one thing everyone has done
with distractions of summer that they're
ready to kick things into high gear we
call it the second new year september
1st everybody's back in gear again and
as august comes to a close you need to
get ready to
come into the fall ready to roll and uh
we're running our 10 special on a whole
lot of things right now and today's deal
is our family favorite uh adventure pack
our team is marking down to only 45.99
lowest price of the year check it out on
check out daily for new deals and always
check out ramseysolutions.com
and always again for the ramsey cash
giveaway you can text cash to 337 899
text cash to
789
catherine is in uh springfield missouri
hi catherine welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
and also
i just want to thank you for your show
because i find it very encouraging
i'm not one of the smart people or the
big money earners
but i am
single
and
dependent only on myself and it's just
been very encouraging to me to to hear
your show and
just keep plugging along well we are
honored to have you and you're among
friends because ken and i are not one of
the smart people either
especially me emphasis on ken
[Laughter]
hey we you know hey i love uh slightly
above average students who go out and
become successful and that's me and you
that's the three of us how can we help
today
well i have gotten
two credit card companies
that have sent me
new cards they're identical to the old
card only they include the tap to pay
and i'm tempted to
destroy the new ones since they're
identical
then i'm just wondering is
is there a reason i should keep the tap
to pay
well tap to pay in and of itself is not
um
bad of course we teach people to only
use debit cards
i don't have i don't have any credit
cards i have debit cards and debit cards
today um almost all of them have a chip
in them
and that's that's all come about in
really the last four years or so in the
u.s it was widespread in europe before
it was here but most of our debit and
credit cards now have a chip
and so when you uh for instance i'm
buying gas this morning and i put it
into the uh the gas pump it it
identifies with the chip that it is a
debit card it doesn't he used to have to
ask me if it was a debit or credit now
it identifies it and tells me to put in
my pin
um and a matter of fact a lot of the
credit cards now have you put in a pin
as well on a pay on a point of sale
transfer because they're trying to do
that to avoid uh fraud and so forth but
uh the biggest thing you want to
remember with all these products is just
the easier they make the transaction to
occur the more you buy
right
and that's the only thing as long as you
know that as long as you know that in
your guard against it you know it's like
amazon prime it's a very easy
transaction you can just sit there and
push that little button all day and crap
will show up on your front porch you
know it's just it's just really really
easy and you tend to spend more the
easier it is to do the transaction the
harder more cumbersome the transaction
marketers call that friction
uh then the more it slows you down and
makes you realize you're actually doing
a transaction you're actually giving
someone money so as long as you're aware
of that i don't care if you use apple
pay
i don't care if you wave a wand and do a
dance i uh i mean there's all kinds of
different ways to pay for things these
days but all of them just about are
trying to make it easier and easier and
easier to do the transaction because all
the merchants know
that consumers spend more that way
yeah
yeah well mine usually stay in the
drawer
but i have my house on the market right
now
so my realtor said don't leave things in
the drawer so i have to keep them in my
purse and i'm wondering is it safe to
keep these in my purse yeah yeah i mean
you're fine because it's got fraud
protection on it if they got stolen you
just turn it in for fraud you're not
you're not responsible for transactions
on a thefted credit card
now if somebody took it out and used it
and put it back it might be a little
while before you realized it when you
got the statement or something but um
but that would be true of a debit card
or anything else and again
we tell you to not use credit cards at
all
uh a debit card will do everything a
credit card will do except put you into
debt it has the exact same protections
for fraud the exact it's just as safe i
still see stupid people on the internet
say oh i got i don't carry a debit card
it's not safe it's just exactly as safe
as your credit card if if you misuse
your credit card you get to pay for it
if someone misuses your credit card for
you call fraud or theft you don't have
to pay for it same is true with a debit
card it's all exactly the same ken yeah
it is and there's just this myth out
there and i think that's do you think
the credit card companies are behind all
that dave i suspect maybe they are
well urban legends out there sure they
don't you know of course if you go to
wheat if you go to visa or mastercard's
website you'll see it it's a zero
liability policy on both their sites
for both products debit or credit either
one and our bank protects us dave go to
a other city in the country and i i find
i'll tell them ahead of time they'll
stop purchases as a protection that's
why they'll do that on credit or debt
yes they will because they are liable
for the
fraudulent transactions
jacob is in carthage texas hi jacob how
are you
man i'm doing great to talk to you dave
and ken hey man what's up
i am 26 uh my wife and i are in baby
steps four five and six and uh thanks to
your plan and
because of that i am chasing my dream of
being self-employed cool um
but i'm finding
really finding it really difficult
to balance
working my side hustle because my
full-time job being a dad being a
husband being involved in my church
it's like i'm starving my side hustle
and i'm never giving it
i don't know if i'm ever going to give
it enough to for it to prove itself what
is it what are you doing i don't know
i make
handmade bass lures that sell for you
know over a hundred dollars a piece
and uh what's your margin on those
uh almost nothing on material yeah
what's the time what does it take to
produce one time wise
as of right now because i'm so small
scale i have like one day that i get to
work on them a week and i can i can turn
one out in a couple hours okay i haven't
really there are ways so if you sell it
for 100 bucks your material cost is
almost nothing and it took two hours
you're making 50 an hour
correct yeah and the faster i can do it
the more money i can make and i'm and
i'm gonna work on investing in some
better production
practices to help me turn out more yeah
i was going to say i would be patient on
this because you've got a lot going on
in your life right now but you know this
is going to be a math equation you know
at some point once you can get this
thing up and going no matter how long it
takes
uh and it replaces your day job income
with where you're at and baby steps four
five and six that's when you do it but
you're eventually gonna have to not only
figure out the production issues but
then train people and slowly grow this
thing so you're gonna have to be patient
regardless that's what i'm kind of
telling you but i wouldn't quit on it
just because you're in a season right
now where you have limited time but i
would impatient here's the thing you
need to just sit down with a calendar
and choose yeah what you're going to do
with your time
and then be satisfied with that and then
be satisfied with your choice
yeah no guilt i'll be looking for new
employment no i mean not necessarily
more time not necessarily so um here's
the thing um
christy wright says in her new book it's
a beautiful line she says balance is not
doing everything equally balance is
doing the right thing at the right time
and for this season
of your life for the next 12 months
what is the right thing to do with your
time there's not a right or wrong answer
it's what do you want to do with it
and so if you want to be on fewer church
committees and make more bass lures
that's okay
that's that could be the right thing for
you
and you just got to lay that out and
decide which one is which
for now and it learned to be permanent
but for now
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we talk to you about your
career your life your money whatever it
is you want to talk about we're here for
you the phone number triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
john is with us to start off this hour
in tulsa oklahoma hi john welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
good to talk to you today um
we
i'm in a bit of a mess i
i moved for i moved from uh
texas in
january
and uh of 2021 this year and
this is the first time we've moved out
away from from everyone
um with first time we had left the city
that we we
spent our whole lives in
and so we took a big leap of faith
and got out here to tulsa and um
we just really
really kind of gotten ourselves in a
bind
i was i was listening to you hard and
heavy for about three months straight
before we before we moved and we had big
big plans to
sit down and talk through some things
and figure some stuff out and we didn't
and i made a lot of dumb decisions since
then
and we're in all kinds of debt we've got
from credit cards to loans to student
loans car payments
and we're just in over our heads so
so deep that we're trying to figure out
what to do you know
[Music]
so if you were completely free would you
move back home
i don't think so
okay
so what is the
was just the stress of being away from
what was uh
familiar you think that added to the bad
decisions is that why you're telling us
about that part of it
yes definitely i do believe so there was
there's a lot of uh with my wife and i
we
we
we let we we pastored for several years
and
for five years and and so we were out of
ministry for one year and we
we fully believe god spoke to us to move
to tulsa
did you take another pastor right there
no i did not um i'm also a plumber i've
i've i'm a i've got a master license in
texas i have a business there still that
generates a little bit of money um and
i've worked for a plumbing company here
in this area
um
my wife is not working right now but
she's she's about to go back to work and
so that's going to help us a lot i know
what do you make now
probably about i make about 78 with with
one the one company it's probably close
to 100 sometimes and what does she what
will she make
um we'll probably be in 100 i would say
100 to 120 range together combined all
right i'm going to call it 120 because
you told me 100 before you said she went
back to work all right so yeah um now
how much
is your house payment
it's 14.50 a month okay and what do you
owe on the cars
each
now okay 42 000
on one uh-huh
and i took out a loan a person a couple
of personal loans and one of them is
tied to my truck now and so that one
that totals about 12 000.
okay
and you already had student loans before
you moved
yes and how much are the the student
the student loans they equal about 60
000.
you say each
uh they they're about they total about
they total about 60. okay so 42 12 and
60. what other debts
um oh credit cards more loans
credit cards are probably about eight
thousand
um somewhere in there maybe a little
less loans are around twenty thousand
just personal loans
yes okay so how much of this did you do
since you moved
um the the student loans in one car were
previous the big car that was all
previous
about half of the credit cards were
previous the new loans and credit card
debt is since removed
okay
so how can i best help you
we're i just i don't even know we're
we're just such a at such a loss right
now and and
there was a lot of bad decisions like i
said that that combined us together
making dumb dumb things and
we finally got back to church um we just
i'm wondering if there's like a group
here in tulsa that we can
find that that is a ramsay group is
there a way to find that sure we'll just
put you into uh ramsey plus into um you
know financial peace university and
there's a lot of churches teaching that
live and you can plug into that i'll pay
for that and help you get started um
okay
your language covers
the words you're using and the way
you're using them covers a lot of other
mistakes that aren't financial it sounds
like
yeah there there has been okay there's
been some different okay let's just
leave that there because it's the weight
of this doesn't the weight of this in
your voice doesn't really match your
numbers
that's why i was asking so um
so what if i said uh okay we're going to
get really together you and your wife
are going to work tight together you're
going to be on beans and rice rice and
beans you're not going to see the inside
of a restaurant unless you work there
and you're not going on vacation and
you're selling her stupid butt 42 000
car what if i said that
that that's i we're we're on board we're
we're ready we we're both ready but
we've just been talking about it and
we're ready to do it now yeah you guys
you got to start doing some stuff that's
going to hurt
yeah there's some pain involved and
living like no one else so that later
you can live and give
like no one else and
and we're ready
yeah we just need some help to get
started i believe okay you know you know
sell a bunch of crap and you're gonna
cut your lifestyle to nothing
yeah you've been you've been eating
candy so much you've got a stomachache
so it amounts to
yes
like yeah like i take one of my
grandkids to the ice cream store and let
them just you know completely founder
themselves and then they're on a sugar
high and their belly hurts right
yes
and i you know what i
john i'm i'm just going to say this i'm
not going to make you respond to it but
i think it's time for you and your wife
to forgive
yourselves there's some shame there's
some pain that's driving some of these
decisions at some point you're going to
have to say god still loves us we still
have a lot of value to ourselves to our
family to our friends and to him
you need to forgive yourself and and
move forward today plumbers are as
valuable to the kingdom of god as
preachers are yeah
well and you don't have to be a preacher
for god to love you yeah
matter of fact i'm pretty sure god might
love some plumbers more than some
preachers
i could have tested that day from a
personal experience i'll just leave it
at that
i'm kidding not really
[Laughter]
yeah
hang on buddy
kelly i'll pick up we'll get you signed
up for a financial piece you jump in
there and go change your life you're
ready you are definitely ready i hope
she is it's gonna be a rough ride for
the next 14 months this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
danielle is with us danielle is in
germantown maryland hi danielle how are
you
hi mr ramsey i'm doing well how are you
today better than i deserve what's up
and hi mr coleman um i want to say uh
first of all it's a pleasure to talk to
you guys and i want to also say a huge
thank you to you
mr ramsay because of you and your
principles not only have my husband and
i been able to um
pay off debt and you know with a lot of
hard work and a literal prayer miracle
um we were able to pay off our debt and
be debt-free six months early yeah
he thinks and that's also freed me to
pursue you know this god-given call that
i have to um open a christian school
right outside of our nation's capital so
i'm really excited about all of that
cool wow which leads me to my question
flash problem um last week i was
listening and you told
a young lady that you really want to
rewrite this narrative that in order to
do righteous work you have to be broke
and i completely agree i feel like you
shouldn't have to be um but the problem
that i see particularly for uh private
schools and especially christian schools
is that there's a revenue problem um
most christian schools most private
schools rely almost 100 percent on
tuition
and
that poses a problem because you can't
pay teachers what they deserve to be
paid
ken i think you said the national
average is about 60 000 and i know in
many schools
um teachers in private schools
especially christian schools are getting
paid less than that and in order to pay
them more you typically have to hike up
tuition but then that's breaking the
backs of the people that you truly want
to serve and so i just wanted to know
what are your thoughts on how we can
fix this problem and rewrite this
narrative because i 100 agree with you i
just can't think of the solution how old
is the school and how many students do
you have
so um it is
it's an i'm actually in an interesting
situation i'm just joining the school
the school has been running for 21 years
it's a niche school for um students with
learning differences from
sixth grade through twelfth grade and
the hope is to grow that um ultimately
from preschool to 12th grade in the
coming years
okay
and what's the uh cost of tuition right
now for 60 approximately um 20 000 a
year yeah
so if you were gonna pay teachers more
have you run a model out as to how that
would affect your tuition
so
i have not honestly um
this miracle kind of just happened where
i'm just now starting with this job but
i will say that um
from our what i know of our finances
right now most of that goes towards
teacher salaries and um
and the reason that the tuition is what
it is is that um to cover those things
but we tend to not when you include
jesus in a lot of things you don't get
to
you don't really qualify for um a lot of
the grants or other things you've done
but i have not okay so first thing first
thing i think you got to run the model
okay because you got to really see all
right if if we were to raise uh the
salaries of our teachers by x amount of
dollars you just run the numbers and
then you've got to play that out you got
to know what you're dealing with first
the second thing i would recommend is
that i think uh and by the way i'm very
very drawn to your mission uh i have a
child that requires some special uh
education services and i love what
you're doing and these families uh
almost come to this school almost as a
last resort it's it's a real oasis i'm
guessing and yeah yeah so couple things
you got going on there um because of the
demand of that uh i think you've got to
look at separate fundraising i think
you've got to really come up with a
model where we're going to we're going
to offset tuition by we're going to get
really serious about raising money and
that you're going to get to some high
net worth individuals that's going to
take some time but i think that's got to
be a strategy long term and then um i
would also tell you that
part of this is uh is opening up more
space if you can do that when you get
more kids then it kind of scales out so
there's really no silver bullet answer
but
um i think that if you can make the case
over time and you're winning for these
families and it doesn't get too
ridiculous
i think with those three strategies you
can get those salaries up into at least
the average in your area
how many teachers do you have
um we have about six teachers some of
them are part-time some are full-time
six
teachers
yes
right now we have like 22 kids
so i thought it was much larger than
that no we're at 22 pretty small okay
and so if you raise the six teachers ten
thousand dollars that would be sixty
thousand dollars
divided by 22 would be three thousand
dollars a piece
that's the model he's talking about
okay and then you say
oh wait we're going to raise it five
thousand dollars because we have some
kids we want a scholarship
right and that's
there are a few that are on a financial
assistant there'll be a few more because
you're bumping it from 20 to 25. yeah
yeah and you know and you're going to
raise your but that's an example of how
you'd model the math out
um of how to play into it and to decide
uh from there
um
you
probably and again the type of care and
what you're plugged into i don't know
i'm not an expert on that world just
from a business viewpoint though
uh having run stuff with
six people or 60 people uh having run
stuff with now a thousand people on our
team
you will get some economies of scale
that will help your situation as well if
for instance you could double your
enrollment and double your teaching
staff yeah now you're not gonna do that
in 20 minutes
but over time if you had 50 students
instead of 25
things are going to work a lot easier
because right now every single
check that is written by a student for
tuition by a parent for tuition
uh is a is a backbreaker if it doesn't
come in you are because you're spread
across so few people
and so your risk your volatility is much
higher on a percentage basis
everyone is living more by the threat by
thread rather than there's no wiggle
room which as you get a little bit more
scale you've got a little bit more
margin a little bit more slosh
that you can do and still still be
responsible
with your salaries
and with your other but i think a
combination between
some students are going to get served by
the higher tuition
with scholarships
because we now have room to do that
um and some are going to get served with
um
by lowering the the net cost of the
tuition by uh fundraising like ken's
saying uh but all the while keeping the
fact that this mission is vital and
really matters yeah
and i think that's the whole thing you
aim at is to go those directions there's
a lot going on here but
um it it truly is more difficult to run
a 22-person thing
than a 50-person thing yeah yeah yeah
and i and again i i i think if you can
get some quality businesses who
understand the vision and the mission of
the organization and they help with that
scholarship fund you can get that thing
going you know and and and really begin
to create almost a miniature endowment
too i mean there's not a whole lot of
effort here and here's what's
interesting it doesn't take but one or
two of those that's exactly right deep
pockets and a person like her
she's just personally saying
she's just the person for the job i
agree she just she just oozes this stuff
it's perfect i mean daniel you're you're
amazing i'm proud of you yeah you get
after it kiddo get after it hey let me
ask you a quick follow-up on that dave
because i don't know the answer to this
if if she were to go raise let's just
say a hundred or two hundred thousand
what would that what fun could they put
that in to be able to let that to start
to earn just like it would for an
individual to where maybe that
self-funds three or four kids every year
you can sit down some of our smart just
one of our smartphones smart investor
pros does endowment funding and so and
what you want to do is just go on the
conservative side but not so
conservative that's earning no money
but um
you know i'll give an example all right
if you had a quarter of a million
dollars laying there at 10 that's 25
000. yeah
every year yeah forever yeah exactly so
every 250 000 you raise and put into an
endowment fund sends a kid free forever
yeah as an example right that's what
endowment means that's how an endowment
works at these colleges and some of
these universities that are sending all
the kids home because they're not
vaccinated or sending them home because
of covet or sending them home have a
billion dollars sitting in an endowment
fund
oh we're getting ready to see some more
people there baby
yeah higher education you are up a creek
you got some problems coming your way
the way some of y'all are acting it's
getting ready to be a
mess
getting ready to be a mess
i was a little bit i thought it was
going to be a little while longer but it
looks like covet is going to hasten it
wow
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're struggling with money
it's easy to tell yourself that you'll
deal with it later or that you'll start
fresh at the new year
but then later rolls around
and you're still stressed you're still
out of control don't wait
you need to start right now decide right
now that this is the last month you will
ever worry about money
if you make that decision we want to
help
and that's why for this month only just
for a little while longer here in august
we're knocking 30 off a 12-month
membership
to our most impactful life-changing
money products
with a ramsey plus membership you get
access to financial peace university
it's our step-by-step plan to save money
pay off debt build wealth
be outrageously generous
and you get the premium version of the
budgeting tool every dollar which is the
world's best budgeting tool
and it'll help you put your plan into
action
financial peace university in every
dollar have helped
millions and millions and millions of
families literally
you deserve a life free
of monthly payments and money stress
call for a free trial stock for us text
for a free trial of ramsey plus
by texting trial
to 3370
789 33 789 text trial
to 3378 for a free trial
of ramsey plus
jay is with us jay is in las vegas hi
jay welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave it's great to be here i'm pretty
excited honored to have you how can we
help
my wife and i are looking towards buying
a business which is a gate installation
company for hoa communities
and the appraisal for it's worth about
1.5 and it makes one to 200 a year
from for the owners if they work in the
business it's not worth 1.5
right well we're having a second
appraisal done by the bank that that's
uh we're trying to get a loan from to
see if we can have that which is what we
decided it's actually worth
but we're wondering if we should even go
for that or should we sell the
properties that we have in order to pay
cash
okay
jay um
30 years ago in my 20s i went broke
and lost everything because i borrowed
money to run a business
it was partly because i was stupid but
it's partly because debt increases risk
and the borrower is slave to the lender
so since i've been on the radio in the
last 30 years i've never told someone to
borrow money
on anything
except i don't yell at you for doing it
on a house
but i've never told someone to borrow
money to buy a business ever in 30 years
so um that's that that's probably
information you didn't know when you
called but um just to kind of let you
know where i'm coming from so that you
you have a fair understanding so where i
and i don't borrow money i don't have a
dime of debt and i haven't in decades
consequently i make a lot of money and i
keep all of it except taxes and
generosity
and so i've been able to build
inordinate amounts of wealth because i
don't give it all to some stupid but
bank and i don't lose money and lose
entire segments of business every time
there's a problem because if there's a
pandemic or something like that and
people quit building gates to hoas
and you have a bank payment the bank
doesn't care they still want their
stinking payment because they're a
stinking bank
and so i'm not going to tell you to go
in debt to a stinking bank to buy an
overpriced business
and this business is dramatically
overpriced we'll come back to that in a
minute yeah okay so if you have the
assets to sell
and pay cash for the business
if i were in your shoes that's the only
way i could do the transaction and i
don't recommend people do things that i
wouldn't do this is a show about what i
would do what ken would do in these
situations okay so you're saying you
have enough real estate to sell and you
have the cash to buy the business is
that right
that's right yeah and so you need to
decide do you want the business more or
the real estate more
now here's a good rule of thumb
after all expenses are paid including
running the business
working in the business
if i were to buy this gate business and
i don't live in vegas
i would have to have someone run the
business okay
you follow me
yeah so i want to look at the p l
as if that has happened
so what does it take to put a manager in
the seat where this owner is working his
own job
now after that manager is paid whatever
market rate to put that manager that
business manager in place
what am i going to make as an absentee
investor
as a return on my money
and that's the profit after a manager's
pay do you agree with me do you
understand
yes sir this is what the business is
worth
a multiple of that net profit
otherwise you're just buying a job
if you buy the j if you buy a business
and the only income it makes is the
wages that should have been paid to the
guy running the business you just bought
a job
that's all you did don't do that you
don't you never buy a job if you're
gonna work a job go work for somebody
keep all your money in your pocket don't
go buying the opportunity to make wages
you want to make you want to make wages
if you're working in the business and a
return on your investment so let's
pretend that this business makes a
hundred thousand dollars a year after
the manager is paid which isn't going to
be far off
okay okay now if i want a 20 rate of
return on my money as an investor
then i would divide the 100 000 by 0.2
or multiply by 5 which is the same thing
that would make this business worth
500 000
okay
if i want a 25 rate of return on my
money
which by the way this is a high-risk
business it's a high-risk thing so i
want a high rate of return on my money
because it's a small business the
probability of failure is much higher
than if i put money in mutual funds or
real estate
yeah so if i want a 25 rate of return on
my money i divide by .25 or i multiply
by four
which means this business is worth four
to five hundred thousand if it's netting
a hundred thousand this thing ain't
worth anywhere near 1.2 dude
okay
uh and i don't know i don't know who
your appraiser is but he ought to have
his butt kicked up around his neck and
wear it like a collar
people will tell you this but this is
how the real world works big time
companies they do the same basic formula
this is how you this is mergers and
acquisitions it's a cap rate that's
right on that operating income of the
business this is a standard valuation
process and so how you get to a million
two on this
i don't know what kind of dance this
guy's doing with it there's something
going on 10 times revenue if it's he
actually net 100 000 yeah which we're
not even 100 sure which means you're
making 10 percent on your money right
i mean and you can make more than that
and mutual funds said at home and i
wonder how valuable the real estate is
clearly valuable enough to come up with
1.5 million so what he said he said he
had enough to be able to cover the 1.5
million appraisal yeah his real estate's
making him more than this
so i think you gave him the right thing
what's more valuable to you because this
is an expensive job
be very careful here there's a lot of
warning signs in what you described to
me unless i misunderstood something you
were saying which is possible sometimes
i do but i don't think i did
so but i think he's going to go and buy
it anyway
felt like it felt like uh wants to hear
that bank's appraisal and the banks got
it they they want to juice that value
what i want from a bank zippo on an
appraisal i can tell you that
this is an open parking spot
when i get there that's what i want from
them
that's good i don't want a bank advising
me on anything
i don't want them advising me on my
dadgum estate plan i don't want their
trust department handling my dad come
kids stuff when i'm gone i just want
their checking account to balance and be
where i told them it was gonna be yeah i
don't need a banker's advice on
investing for sure
good lord they're a banker
think about it geez
they couldn't get a good job
wow
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today christina is in ocala
florida hi christina welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave and ken thank you for taking my
call this is a wonderful birthday
present
oh happy birthday
thank you it's the big 4-0 it's kind of
scary oh
i don't know how you're going to make it
old woman
i know that's what my husband said poor
me
um i have a question because my husband
and i have been working our baby steps
which is wonderful and
we're kind of concerned on how to deal
with his father
we want to handle it in a way that his
retirement is going to be a blessing
instead of a new curse for us
let me give you a little background he
is a single man and has been
since him and his mom divorced 40 years
ago
he spent the last 20 years
renting he's never bought or owned a
home he
at one point leased and owned three cars
a boat jet ski and two motorcycles he's
always had more than one car and he's
one person
um
he's retired now all he has is social
security a little bit of pension and a
hundred thousand dollars to his name and
he thinks buying a gun is an investment
and we're just terrified that
we need to fit him into our baby steps
because we're gonna end up having to
take care of him if we can't get him to
stop wasting money
okay um
what do you guys make a year
130 000 i work four jobs and run a
business trying to clean up our own mess
and
we have our own goals and dreams and i
just feel like one out of guilt we're
all he has i mean my husband is his only
son
um you know there's nobody else that's
gonna take him in it would have to be us
so
i feel like if we could get him on the
right path he might be okay but that's
having to explain to him that you know
what you're gonna have to stop blowing
money
and maybe work a part-time job because
he thinks he can buy a house but that's
going to take all his money if that's
even enough
[Music]
a hundred thousand dollars by much how
old is he
68
house houses health
uh well he just had surgery for prostate
cancer but that all went well so
we're hoping the health maintains but
that's my other concern your husband has
a good relationship with his dad
oh yeah we've always been close with him
and we have a good relationship and a
couple of years ago we sat down and
talked to him about all this
and kind of tried to explain to him
making eight percent he's got some
finance guide his credit union telling
him making eight percent and whatever he
has been that he doesn't understand is
good we're like no
that's not good and he thinks it is and
he doesn't understand half of what
they're doing they just he gives them
his money and they do whatever and he
thinks it's good
and after that many years of them doing
whatever all you have is a hundred
thousand dollars to show for it i think
you need a new guy
i think you're more upset about this
than anybody else on the planet
well it terrifies me yeah i don't think
you're i don't think your husband's
upset about it and i don't think his
dad's upset about it
well my husband's worried because he
doesn't not as worried as you the other
day
well
i'm nervous to talk to you too but my
husband's like i need to talk to him but
you know how do i talk to him without
you know hurting his feelings or being
kind of a jerk about it because like
he's rented a house for 30 years paying
250 a month now i can just tell you you
don't need to talk to him
because your state of mind is not a
state of mind that he's going to listen
to you
well no i won't talk to him my husband
has to yeah your husband has to
not my problem i know i know but it's um
you're you're
because you're you're um you have a lot
of anxiety about this and it's going to
come through
and it's going to sound bossy to him and
you don't want that it won't be it won't
be uh profitable for the conversation
your husband can sit down and talk to
him but i i'll give you a prediction
your husband can sit down and talk to
him and probably nothing's gonna change
okay because i don't think the old man
wants to change
i don't think he gives a rip
right
so he's 68 years old he's 68 years old
he has a hundred thousand dollars he
buys guns
um and he pays his rent in cars
well he just now found out he has to
move out of that so now he just went and
dumped money to rent a trailer until he
can figure out where he wants to live
okay
on top of his two cars
one of the most painful things that we
all go through as adults is watching
people we care about be stupid
[Laughter]
because you can't make them not be
stupid
everyone has people in their family and
in their friend group that are doing
things that we all look at them and go
um
and you you know the the only hope is is
that occasionally you can knock a knot
on one of them's head and get their
attention and turn them around
but i don't hear anything in this story
that makes me think he's going to listen
to your husband do you really think
there's any scenario where your husband
says can you i don't have any magic
words for your husband to use
and i just don't think this old man
really cares about i think he's got his
own way of doing things and i don't
think he uh cares so here's the thing
you make 130 000 a year you can probably
buy him a little bit of groceries if
he's completely starving to death
you might even help him with his rent a
little bit here or there a few times
even though he's been a complete twerp
with money and doesn't really deserve
with his irresponsibility to help but
you can afford to dump a little bit of
money in that and you're it's not going
to make you broke you're not going to
give this guy a hundred grand yeah
nor do you have to pay off his debt all
those boats and cars you can sell all
that if something happens to him yeah
you're not responsible for any of that
yeah all we want to do is just make sure
he's not hungry and homeless yeah
well yeah that was kind of our point
it doesn't take a lot of money
i mean it doesn't take a lot of money if
if you're paying his rent you decide
where he
lives or he doesn't have to live there i
mean i'm gonna get a little cheap a
little cheap uh trailer or a little one
bedroom apartment or something let him
rent
and you can do that depending on where
he is a few hundred here are there right
and uh the same thing with groceries so
and you guys can afford to do that and
by the time you have to do it which will
be many years from now if you ever even
do have to do it your wealth is going to
be on track because you're doing smart
stuff
but it's just it's just i agree with the
pain in your voice
and the desperation in your voice
because it's just hard
to watch people you care
be self-destructive
yeah i mean well yeah when we feel like
he we're it that we have to
no you don't you don't yeah you don't
have to
you don't have to do anything
there's not a law
that says
you've done cocaine your whole life and
now i'm supposed to pay for your rent
there's no i mean you've misbehaved
whatever form of misbehavior you want to
come up with your whole freaking 70
years on the planet
and you're and now i'm obligated to feed
you not really but i probably will just
because i'm a compassionate person
he's not going to take you guys down you
either have so much fear and i get it
there's so much unknown and you're in
the middle of a struggle and you guys
are busting in your gazelle intention
you're working four jobs and you're
going going going going but listen he's
not going to drag you down he's not
going to drag you guys down so that fear
needs to go away but he's it's
disgusting sure of course because you're
working so hard and he's not doing squat
yeah
you know you're being so responsible and
he's so irresponsible i get that it's
disgusting to me to hear about him and i
don't even know him
you know i get it i i understand but
he's what is he he's most of america
right yeah and so he's irresponsible and
slovenly and out of control and you know
and and then acts like somebody did
something to him and nobody did anything
to this old guy
he just farted around all his money till
it was gone
right
yeah yeah so i i i think you can calm
and and just lovingly i mean
please don't talk to him let your
husband
and his son and just say dad i'm gonna
knock a knot on your noggin if you don't
quit this
because i'm afraid i'm gonna have to
feed your butt because you're
misbehaving now you need to be grown up
and this is how he needs to talk to him
because this whole guy doesn't do
subtlety does he
no no he needs a tube
he needs a two before upside the head
and that's that's what your son's gonna
have to do but that's the only shot he's
got getting through to him and it's just
lovingly dad i love you but you're being
a butt
and you gotta stop it and you're just
going to have to have this conversation
and then see how it goes
hallmark needs to make one of those
cards right there the dave ramsey dad i
love you but you're being a butt
that's that'll be a
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host ken
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five
rusty is in odessa texas hey rusty
what's up
hey guys how are you great man how can
we help
you're doing well hey i've been
following your plan for about 20 years
uh we're on baby step 7. i wanted to ask
you a question about something that
we're starting to see
is places that are no longer taking cash
or basically penalizing those of us that
are using cash like
entertainment places where you have to
put cash on a on a play card um and then
if you don't use all of it you don't get
it all back we're just curious your
thoughts about that
i'm not familiar with that type of
transaction
uh
you know i mean obviously there's
situations where i just look as a matter
of principle i choose not to do business
with somebody
by the way by the they are putting forth
barriers to me
they're requiring things of me as a
customer
uh maybe around covid or around cash or
something that i don't want to do
and therefore i don't do it and that
means i can't be their customer and
that's okay they own the business
they're allowed to say that
um right as far as i know the whole
legal tender thing
won't work i mean they're supposed to
accept legal tender that's the whole
purpose of a currency but i don't know
of anyone enforcing that
at the federal level which is what it
would have to be i guess so i think
that's probably more of a philosophical
discussion than anything else
but i carry a debit card so if i'm in a
situation like that um unless the people
are just being weird or something i i i
use a debit card to run a tab at a place
or something if i need to but i'm not
going to give somebody cash it's
non-refundable if i don't use it all
right what is that like a club like a
nightclub thing yeah it's like a it's uh
like an entertainment that has like
movies and bowling alleys and game rooms
and things like that oh yeah it's like a
dave and busters type thing or something
or a chucky cheese exactly right yeah
okay
all right yeah i'm not uh no i mean that
will they take a debit card
they will but i like to use my cash okay
well i don't blame you there i mean i
don't blame you but so it comes down to
you know a
horrible transaction which is the plate
thing you were describing i'm not doing
that for sure uh or i like to use my
cash and you people are making this
difficult and so you're basically saying
i don't want you as a customer rusty and
you say okay then i won't be your
customer i'll go
i'll go bowling somewhere else you know
and so there you go i'll look for my
excitement elsewhere
um or you can use if it's something
you're you're not uh wanting to take a
stand on you know it's not i mean i
don't make a principled
uh
uh
picketing uh stand on every single
transaction i do i just look at it and
go you know this one's not worth it i'm
not fighting this one or this one i'm
gonna fight and i'm not gonna do this
and so
you know i uh um
you know i i uh so anyway you just got
to decide that and and say
uh
i'm not going there but you're right
there's more and more places that have
gone to
cashless i was in a
uh
a breakfast place
a tiny little meat and three breakfast
place off the side of the beaten path up
off of uh
outside of aspen colorado last year
and they didn't take cash and i was like
god um i mean it was like a biscuits and
gravy kind of thing
like it wasn't like some kind of
froofroo thing or something you know
yeah and uh i i went in there and i was
like god
i just wonder i didn't leave my debit
card like back at the hotel or something
i would have to go back and get that
yeah or you know what the reason is keep
my what in their case
they were doing it uh because they were
well it's aspen i mean they're just
they're frou-frou right so the food
wasn't fruitful but they have the little
thing come to the table and you know and
check you out with this high-tech thing
at the table
the biscuits weren't high-tech but the
payment methodology was high-tech
they're paying for that and so yeah they
are and uh like three percent every time
you swipe for yourself for biscuits i'd
take a dollar but uh um but that's you
know so anyway i was just i had a pocket
full of cash i always do but yeah thank
goodness i had a debit card because
sharon would probably still be there
washing dishes but
i would love to see a disagreement from
dave ramsey i'm just like and i stopped
pay for my meal dave's in the back
washing dishes
and then they found out who you were
they'd probably make you mop the floor
too yeah twice twice just for good
measure that's fantastic yeah but i mean
that that's the kind of thing he's
running into
um and there was a there was a minute
during cove but i haven't heard it
lately that some places quit taking cash
because they thought the lokovids were
on the money and um
there wasn't any i'm sorry i'll try not
to laugh but you just said little kovids
well i think they thought that you know
everybody was worried about what the
covington these little jurors like when
they show those uh cleaning commercials
the bugs and they met well they were i
mean they were everywhere for a while
and
now they're now they now they only use
certain channels so um apparently but um
you just gotta you gotta know how they
behave these days so
they don't like plexiglas i'll tell you
that well i don't know the plexiglass
has come down a lot of places now i was
on a donut shop the other day and there
was plexiglas before and now it's down
so yeah i went to a couple of amusement
parks this summer
and i told my wife i said we should have
gotten to the we should have found some
company to invest in
yes i should have opened a plexiglass
company that would have been a boom last
year yeah that would have been a nice
roi on that yeah that's you know there's
situations like that where they wouldn't
take cash because they're worried about
germs yeah and uh money is germy there's
no question about that yeah don't put
that in your mouth it's true and
colleen's as well remember that oh yeah
gross all right chad is with us chad's
in atlanta georgia hi chad how are you
hey i'm great how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
well we're in a position where we uh we
owe 163 000
on our mortgage our house and i'm in a
position to pay it off how much money do
you have
i have
well i have 185 000 in cash debt free
we
expect to make 300 000 plus a year cool
what is it you love about being in debt
on your mortgage
party what is it you love about being in
debt on your mortgage i don't love it
but my accountant we have a we have a
small business and um
my accountant has told me that it's a
bad idea to pay off your mortgage
because we're on a
low mortgage rate because we should
invest our money
um and let
i've got five years left on a 10-year
note
uh so what's your house worth
oh this the farm is worth probably 500
000. okay well you should probably go
get a bigger mortgage on it because
rates are down
you'll get a bigger mortgage if you're
gonna keep that accountant you should
because that's what his theory is
my fear my theory however is fire your
accountant and pay off your mortgage
today today
both
because your accountant
doesn't share your values and you have
more money than he does
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure
talk just go to puretalk.com and enter
the promo code ramsey to save 50 off
your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at eight eight
two five five two two five if you are
not strapped with student loan payments
odds are you know someone who is
millions
are putting off things like buying a
house or having kids or even getting
married
they're waiting and waiting
and waiting on the government to save
them
with student loan forgiveness
this is a joke
we produced a new documentary a
full-length document documentary
world-class production
called borrowed future
it follows the track of the borrowed
future podcast only it's better
and millions and millions of you have
listened to the borrowed future podcast
it uncovers the dark side of the student
loan industry and exposes how the system
is built to work against
you
so i want you to save the date and i
want you to tell everybody about it make
a point to watch on october 14th
you'll see folks weigh in on the epic
failure
otherwise known as the student loan
program
with featured interviews from all kinds
of industry insiders
thought leaders like seth godin seth
frond frotman dr john deloney
lots of teens being interviewed
it'll blow your mind
we're coming at this hard i'm going to
tell you some of you aren't going to
like it
which was my intent
and we're taking some big swings at the
student loan problem
we want to educate you parents and
students across the country how evil
this situation is
and you do not have to take out loans to
get a college education
it is possible to graduate debt-free and
avoid the predatory
student loan industry
borrowed future premiers on all digital
platforms or almost all of them
october the 14th
you can find that on your
television program wherever you go and
watch good stuff
and
we'll be listing all the different
places as they as we get them all
contracted as you uh go to
borrowedfuture.com
be sure and mark it down now october the
14th you don't want to miss the premiere
of this
it's going to be a something everyone's
talking about our question of the day is
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings with
free samples free shipping and new
promos all the time
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsay to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from luke in
chicago i'm an accountant with a fortune
500 company making 65 000 a year i'll
get a promotion next year where i'll
earn 75 000 my wife and i are working
the baby steps and will be debt free in
two and a half years i was recently
offered a job in a cpa firm at sixty
thousand dollars that would be more
geared towards actual clients and tax
returns which i've always wanted to see
that side of the industry and i think it
could provide more opportunity for
growth in the long run however i would
be forfeiting the promotion and raise
plus i would have to repay four thousand
dollars for mba classes which were paid
for by my company should i stay at my
current job while working the baby steps
wife going back to school and possibly
having another baby in the near future
or
is it worth taking a chance to pursue
this new career path i would stay put
right now with the one caveat that when
you tell the new offer
that you're grateful for the offer but
it's a pay cut and
it's not a good move for you right now
you're really grateful but it's too much
of a cut based on opportunities at your
current company let's see what they say
how bad do they want you but at the
current offer i would sit tight and this
is hard for people because i get that
luke's saying all right this is kind of
the side of of accounting that i always
had wanted to do but here's the good
news luke you're in a fortune 500
company uh they've trained you looks
like or at least they paid for your
training with an mba you're going to get
a promotion more money and experience
and you're acting as though this is the
only opportunity you'll ever have to
move over to this side of maybe front
facing you know client-facing accounting
work and that's simply not true so it
feels good
to get an offer it makes us feel good we
feel wanted and valuable but you've got
to look at the long term big picture so
the best advice would be sit tight look
for something better
let me ask you this in in the what you
teach um
i know how you teach about asking for
raise service value
if he went back and said
i would be willing to add something to
my duties
at the new place you're talking to your
potential new employer that's right i'd
be willing to do some extra work
so that i didn't get a pay cut
and you had to and you cover my mba
problem right because here's my problem
guys i really want to work over there
yep but i'm making 65 now and it's gonna
cost me four grand in mba if we can
cover that yeah i'll do some extra work
for you
if you'll tell me what to do
um but but to add value but if you but
you got to help me and at least meet
what i'm doing now yeah and if you can't
that's okay i understand i'll just sit
tight but but if you can then i think we
can get a deal done yeah is that is that
an unreasonable as an employer if
someone came at me that way i would not
be offended it's certainly not
unreasonable it's a version of what i
told him to do he could say to them hey
look i can't make this work financially
and then they're going to ask questions
if they're really i would just say what
no i know the only thing i'm concerned
about is if he says if i leave
um you guys would have to and any i
understand your offer but still coming
out of pocket the 4k for his nba that
could raise a flag well you left them
will you leave us
see that's why the company paid for his
nba they kind of put that incentive
there for them not to leave i don't
think it's a red flag but i'm saying it
could be to some
whereas i don't think he has to get into
that i think you can say i'd really like
to be here but you guys aren't this
offer isn't where i need to be and
candidly if my cfo came in
and said uh we have a candidate
and we're offering 60 and he needs 65
and 4 to pay off his mba to come on it's
the guy we want should we do it i would
say do it yeah
and especially in today's hiring
environment well absolutely which is why
i think it's worth for him to just say
look guys i can't do it again yeah
here's what i've got now that's it and i
i can't i got a baby and i gotta i gotta
make this happen that's it and so if we
can make this happen and i don't mind
doing something extra i'll throw in
added value sure yeah i mean the answer
is i like what you said i really like it
it's a little bit it's a little bit more
forward thinking and saying hey a little
bit more aggressive a little bit more
aggressive but it's not going to offend
anybody there's nothing that's and if it
does so what well then there's your sign
yeah
[Laughter]
to borrow a uh
yeah
to borrow a bill involved
it is 25 years i've seen a lot of jeff
foxworthy specialists apparently
all of them memorized
all right whitney's with us in tulsa
oklahoma hi whitney welcome to the
ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
i am currently
transitioning jobs and my current
employer offers a roth 401k which i've
been very happy with but my new employer
is on a pension fund
and i just don't know anything about
pensions or how to kind of navigate that
when i'm saving for retirement they
don't have anything except a pension
no
it's ems and that's
what we get yuck
okay well it's what you get then i mean
they put it all in you're not putting
anything in right
no we have to contribute eight percent
and then they'll match it's what
where are you
oklahoma
what state
oklahoma oklahoma state government
yeah it's the oklahoma public employment
retirement yeah you're working for the
state of oklahoma
yeah okay all right
crap okay well yeah you're putting in
eight percent and something you have no
control over that's probably going to
yield you about six percent
yeah and so in addition to that you need
to be saving for retirement
okay could i roll my roth 401k to a
traditional rock and keep contributing
that way you can roll your roth 401k to
a traditional or to a roth ira and you
should
and you can add new you they're
technically two accounts but every year
you can open
you can open a roth ira separately in
good mutual funds so get in touch with
your smart investor pro and do your
rollover and set up a personal roth
in addition to this pension that you're
doing with the state of oklahoma
that took me a second to catch up with
you i'm sorry i didn't understand where
you were
good question thanks for joining us
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage alex is with us hey alex
how are you man i'm doing great how are
you better than i deserve where do you
live memphis tennessee all right couple
hours down the road made it up here to
do a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off it was just a little under 74
000. excellent and you're uh how long
did this take you
two years
there's a little story i cashflowed
nursing school in between that so oh wow
two years just paying off
okay all right and your range of income
during that time about 80 000 to 110
okay so you're out of nursing school now
yes sir about a year out now what kind
of debt was the 74
um about 50 000 was student loans a car
was 12.
my
dog's eye surgery was 4 000 and like
laptop and just about anything but
credit cards be honest with you okay
just life and uh
but somewhere around that two-year mark
or whatever you woke up as a young
single guy how old are you 32. and you
woke up back in your 20s and said i this
isn't working tell me your story what
happened
um try to keep it brief in about 2015 uh
my mom gave me the total money makeover
and she had a note written in there that
she um she said if you follow this you
know you can
retire a millionaire um we didn't come
from money so
flabbergasted when i saw that i was like
there's no way so naturally what do you
do when somebody gives you a book as a
gift you put it away so yeah you set it
out for a coaster
yes sir so um
fast forward to about 2017 i was in the
middle of a move and i um came across a
book and i read or saw the note and i
was like i'll give it a shot so i read
in a couple of days and i finally had my
i've had a moment you know reading the
stories were inspirational and
it was
after that was just game on just paying
off dead and then um you know cash flow
nursing school in between that so it was
a little pause for 20 months total but
just didn't stop after that wow good for
you so you just tore into it yes sir all
right so once you read it you're like
that's it i'm done let's do it because i
never i mean in my 20s i was just
it never really occurred to me like i
you know made all the payments on time
so it never really kind of clicks so
you're
really you know in the red as far as
negative and i just
finally had my i've had a moment you
know some other my friends were
much further along like you know in life
and going on trips and stuff and i was
like all i'm doing is working paying
bills working paying bills and the
just that
circle got you know
a little tired of it
how much was nursing school do you mind
me asking you did you cash flowed
i think it was
tuition i think was around 20 000. i
mean books and other miscellaneous
stuff's around there but i think it was
about twenty thousand two year program
uh one year one year program
so how far along were you in paying off
debt out of this out of the 74 how much
were you had you paid off as you began
to then go into nursing school i think
it was
maybe a year i'm sorry i'm no it's okay
i think i think it's roughly about a
year yeah really interesting wow
very yeah a cool process yeah so now
you're 32 debt free and a nurse yes sir
awesome rn lpn what rn okay wow that's
awesome career
very good so
very good very cool how does it feel
it still kind of hasn't sank in yet i
mean it's it's very liberating a good
buddy of mine
um he's also debt-free did the program
we went on a celebratory golf trip to
denver um
earlier this month so that's fun oh we
had so much fun it was a blast it was it
was a lot of fun great yeah you ought to
do something like that to celebrate debt
free
i love it very good good for you
and uh
that's pretty incredible so
has it um
emotionally and intellectually sunk in
yet that your mom was right you're going
to be a millionaire
i want to retire with two million now
yeah so yeah it's yeah
it's it's it's
so that's a yes yeah he did the math
and i want 10 million
yes sir it has but it's it's been a it's
been a fun journey but i'm looking
forward to the next uh steps met some or
some people with some edm shirts out
there so that's my uh that's my next
goal yeah it's everyday millionaires
babysit millionaires i love it yeah
that's very cool well you're there man
what was the hardest part for you
um
honestly it's just some days when you
just
you just get tired of doing it over and
over and over again um
the grind i mean it is a grind it really
is a grind yes sir um that's what i
would say it's just just the days that
you're not expecting where you're just
like i don't want to do this i want to
just go out to eat i want to go just
splurge and but you know you just keep
to it and stuff so the good thing is um
i was a
restaurant bartender before that so it
was good having cash every day so i
could throw money at debt just
every couple days so kind of kept me um
you know on the street if you throw it
at the dead it's out of your hands and
you can't do something with it exactly
yeah you're hiding it from yourself yes
sir yeah that's pretty cool that's good
gives you an incentive to work too
because you see those numbers come down
yes sir yeah so what do you tell people
the key to getting out of that is
um
you got to find your why but i mean
mainly the the every dollar budget was
amazing i mean it's just so user
friendly it's very easy and you know and
just
every time you hit a little milestone or
a thousand or something like that you
know it's
you know it's going down but you know
definitely uh just find your why in the
budgeting so what's your why
um
we
my father died at young age and so my
mom had at the time three kids and um
it's no fault of her but we just didn't
have a lot of money um
growing up and so i
realized at a young age whatever i want
whatever i
want in this world you know um i'll have
to go out and get it and so um i just
want to make things you know
better and brighter um kind of write my
own story
going forward
you show your two siblings uh i have
four um we had at the time um when my
father passed away you've got a younger
brother um a different dad but yeah yes
sir so that same message set in on all
of you or just you
trying to get um no no the message of if
i want it i gotta go get it oh 100 100
yes sir yeah that's not a bad message
even if it comes from a place of uh
where your mom was struggling to do
everything and it you know it's a place
of lack
but uh it still it still wakes that part
up in you where and and it never really
goes to sleep again no it's personal
responsibility at a different kind of
visceral level
yeah so yeah she uh she gave me my hard
work uh the discipline of that so i mean
i think her every day for that yeah i
think she's probably a rock star she is
she's great probably pretty incredible
lady yeah very neat so very neat good
stuff yeah great great story who are
your biggest cheerleaders
uh the guy i was looking at at the time
my good friend adam blair did the
program um angie my girlfriend over here
and uh you know families and friends
would always just hey how much you paid
off you know kind of just kind of
reminded me stuff like that but i didn't
have any
um any barriers or anybody like
naysayers and stuff so everybody was
really uh encouraging so it was great
that's helpful yeah that is helpful that
matters a lot having people in your
corner screaming for myself good stuff
man proud of you thank you so much
you're a hero you did it you did what
your mom said and now you're going to go
on and be a baby steps millionaire and
prove it
because she's exactly right you do the
stuff in that book it'll take you there
and good lord you're 32. you're
definitely going to be there
definitely going to be there i love it i
love it all right we've got a copy of
the legacy journey for you because
that's definitely the next chapter like
we're just talking about
in your story and a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away so
that someone can
pack it away with a note that you write
and two years later when they're moving
it'll come out of the box this book gets
out that way
this book has a delayed it's like a
smart bomb it has a delayed reaction
with people you're like the human
version of where's waldo no where's dave
the book keeps popping pops up later i
love that yeah so we're gonna give you
one of those and put a seat out there
for one more person to delay their
change that's that's the way it works so
i love it all right and uh so alex from
memphis
74 000 paid off in two years making 80
to 110
32 and cash flow nursing school what a
rock star count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one i'm debt free
yeah
oh
by the way a cash flow nursing school
attending bar and going to class yes and
past my bars
and
don't call me and tell me you have to
quit work and sit at home and go 50 000
student loan debt to be a nurse okay
because i've met alex that's right and
i've got proof yeah
yeah and don't tell me that uh because
of your debt you can't pursue your dream
ding ding he just did it yeah there's a
coleman there's a ken coleman i see
that's that's why you're here because
you see stuff like that that i don't see
that's good i like it this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day second
chronicles 2015 this is what the lord
says to you
do not be afraid
or discouraged because of this vast army
for the battle is not yours
but gods
babe ruth said every strike brings me
closer
to the next home run
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hunter is with us in atlanta hi hunter
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave um
i'm gonna try and be brief it's a lot
but
basically my
fiance and i are looking to buy a house
shortly
and i need some advice i'm a college
student
i
do work full time
neither of us have any debt i make
between 40 and 45 000 a year while in
school
and she is completing her master's
program
and will be taking over a
number of franchises from that are owned
by her family
she already has
a little over a million dollars in her
trust
and
not long ago i started your plan i'm
done with step one two and three um and
basically i'm i'm curious as to what we
should do from here i know that
obviously debt is
um bad don't want to go into it but i
i struggle seeing the way that we can
purchase a house without using the money
that's in her trust
and without going into debt how old are
you
uh we're about 23. cool when you're
getting married
within
within a year not not the end of this
calendar year but
when will the two of you graduate
um i
well
i am fed up with college honestly and i
just had open heart surgery and i
transferred schools
and changed majors which has put me far
behind um she graduates this december
and i will be done
beginning of next year why are you fed
up with school
i
basically the the line of work that i'm
in i feel like i've gained much more
knowledge there than i
have and ever will in college what do
you do farming is that what you want to
do long term
not necessarily the labor side but i
would be very interested in selling
produce or anything in the ag industry
um so
i would not be opposed to farming but
right i would have to make substantially
more money than what i'm being paid okay
so let's go back to what you just said
based on what you know now what you've
learned and where you're positioned
within the farming and ag industry
does it make sense to you
to stay in school to finish out where
you are do you think it's going to put
you further ahead is it going to get you
qualified to do the thing you ultimately
want to do yes or no
no honestly um
i i don't think so so let me ask you
hold on a second let me ask you an
alternative question so if you stay
let's say you walk today and i'm not
telling you to walk but if you if you
walked you went at this full time and
you worked your way up and you learned
more about what you're doing and you
made great relationships within the
farming in ag and you crossed over into
that specific area you mentioned
could you do that faster and make more
money in the amount of time it would
take you to stay in school and work
part-time
you see i
i have contemplated that exact question
okay myself uh great for quite some time
now and the school that i'm in i'm i'm
getting a degree that is pertinent to
what i do um i'm getting an ag business
degree and a minor in agronomy so
it is it is
you know there's a direct correlation
between my degree and what i plan on
doing and what i am doing now
um well now
ag business will probably would further
you wouldn't it
well and
you would think so but it
i haven't learned anything
and i'm not trying to bash college i
think college is great there's a lot of
people that gain a lot of information
from it um
but me personally i've i've learned
better through hands-on experience i
think
well
to make it short
i am a senior but i still have 30 hours
to go from the
due to the changing major you've not had
any ag business classes that taught you
anything that you didn't already know
because at 23 i was learning accounting
and statistics i didn't know
no
i would i would say that's correct
don't get me wrong i'm not trying to be
boastful i'm not trying to act like a
know-it-all but with me working
on this farm and i'm not talking about
the agriculture part i'm talking about
the business part
oh no so you know accounting inside now
you know statistical analysis and data
analysis inside and out you know uh
marketing inside now without ever having
taken a class
no i have taken a
macro and micro economy but you said you
haven't learned anything
no yeah i made a's in all those classes
with very very little studying
on macro and micro econ
yes and and marketing and the uh right
here's the deal you're 30 hours away
here's the deal hunter you're 30 hours
away go faster finish it up at this
point yeah but but don't be all down in
the dumps about it either decide to move
on or finish i wouldn't buy a house
right now
answer your original question you don't
need to buy a house right now you two
need to get married settle down rent for
uh until both of you finish up your
degrees and then rent for a little while
longer and then buy a house and yes you
can use our trust fund to buy a house by
then but that's going to be two years
into your marriage and you're fine to
rent for the first two years of marriage
it's not the end of the world it's a
little bit of time for you guys to get
your life foundations laid and then
you'll decide she'll be neck deep and
running those franchises by then i take
it she's getting an mba
uh yes that's correct okay cool and that
that was exactly my plan um
let's verbatim uh what we said to do was
to rent for the first year or two
and then look at doing something i just
don't know how i would feel because well
i mean listen you married a woman with a
million dollars
and you're she's gonna buy you're gonna
buy a house with some of that money i
mean
it
you know it's an awkward feeling
because you're you're a guy that works
hard and earns your keep and it doesn't
you feel like you hit the lottery or
something or you're cheating or
something and you're not cheating but
but admittedly it's awkward
um do you think he feels a little bit of
guilt about using some of the trust
money i should have heard a little bit
of that it's awkward yeah yeah who i
mean most people what sure
unless you're unless he's like a gold
digger or something you know but he's
not he's a good guy
and so yeah you're fine i i but i think
you just say out loud this feels awkward
and you know if you want to put a uh
where there's extreme differences in the
wealth of a couple getting married
that's the only time that i am okay with
a prenup
uh and this is pretty extreme uh she's
getting all these franchises and this
trust fund yeah now you don't have
access to the trust fund but if you move
money out of the trust fund and put it
in the house in both your names now you
got access to it so you could have a
prenup to protect her
in the event of that and a will to
protect her in the event of that and so
on so um
you know that's the plan uh but i mean
if that helps you feel less awkward
that would be an okay thing to offer but
i i think that um
you know i think she's probably
protected by the laws in most states
anyway if you used her family money
after marriage to buy a house
um in terms of legally protected so
i but i'm not an attorney you'd have to
check with one to be sure but that's how
i feel about it but i i i do understand
the awkwardness that is a standard
that's a normal feeling ken i love your
advice too because here's the deal
you're right dave she's gonna be fresh
out of an mba program taking on these
franchises for the family business a lot
of self-induced pressure there they're a
young couple gotta learn how to live
together and learn how to be married the
first two years are weird she did she
does life the way that she saw in her
house you do life the way that he that
you saw and so i love the idea of
renting shopping for homes you know and
even though you're not buying look at
what you like and decide take a couple
years to breathe and then make that big
decision i love that for all of those
reasons not just the finances yep that's
the plan hey man thank you for calling
interesting question sharp young man
interesting question i would go ahead
and finish the degree though yeah
i think i think that's i think that's a
win
all right that puts this hour in the
books good show ken appreciate you
hanging out with me ken coleman ramsey
personality today james childs is our
producer back in the chair producing
again kelly daniel the band is back
together
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you